We got the van...
...then we get a text saying she's having second thoughts.
It's just... I don't know.
There's so many different versions of the story and how it could play out.
Okay, we have this girl's van.
We love it.
We were really like, "Yes, we want to buy it."
She was like, "Great!"
And then, "No, I need to think about it."
Then there were some other vans that we've seen...
...that other people have been like, "This is a great car" or whatever.
It just needs some love.
We're not mechanics, so we're a little nervous...
...to buy something that's not road-ready...
...and have to fix it up ourselves.
And then there's the higher end of the price trend...
...which we haven't really seen any of those ones.
They're like 7,000, 7,500.
That price range, we haven't even dabbled in...
...because we really liked this other car.
And that's just a long end up spiel to say that she is now...
On the fence.
...on the fence,...
...told us we could buy the car,...
...and now it's "Uh, I want you to buy the car,...
...but I want you to buy it when I want to sell it."
And now I had Lou write her back,...
...being, "We get that you really want this last trip,...
...but we're in a predicament, too, with the timing, and we're open to paying more."